اخوتي واخواتي الكرام اسعد الله صباحكم
مسائكم بكل خير من هنا من قطاع غزه
انشرلكم اخر تطورات بالقطاع اخوان انا
اليوم جاي اشكر كل انسان شريف بدافع عن
هذه القضيه كانها قضيته اكثر فشكرا لكل
واحد بساعد
وتضامن مع هذه القضيه الفلسطينيه شكرا لك
جزيرا من قلب قطاع غزه المهم اخوان جاي
احكيلكم في موضوع المقاطعه صح اني تاخرت
كثير بس يعني انه اليوم عب ايش حملكم
المهم يا اخوان المقاطعه بتمنى انكم
تقاطعوا المنتجات الاسرائيليه الامريكيه
او اي منتج بيدعم قوات الاحتلال لقتل
النساء والاطفال في قطاع غزه يعني
المنتجات اللي انتم تدعموها
لامريكا المهم اللي انتم قاعدين تدعموها
هذه بيستغلو ويشتروا فيها اسلحه ودبابات
ليقتلوا اطفالكم العربيه في قطاع غزه
ونسائكم وشيوخ تمام ثانيا بيجيلك واحد
راسه مكعب هيك بجيلك بحكيلك انا باثر مين
قاللك بتاثر يعني واحد على واحد اثنين
فاهم علي ف انت بتاثر وهذا باثر وهذا باثر
انت وهو وهو وهو وهو تاثروا بس قاطعوا
ويعني زي القضيه قضيتكم واحنا ايد واحده
وعرب ومعكم عبود من قطاع غزه والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله والوضع يسقف الوضع ي سكف
علي